from at age Bud light's marketing
leadership undergoes shake-up after
Dylan Mulvaney controversy Alyssa
heinershide who has led the brand since
June takes a leave of absence and is
replaced by Budweiser Global Marketing
VP Todd Allen so not fired leave of
absence
wow this is this is a huge move on the
part of anheuser-bit Anheuser-Busch add
age of course for everybody wondering is
newsguard certified 100 out of 100 this
is hard confirmation that this woman has
been temporarily removed from her
position this means it is 100 times
worse than what you think it is it looks
like they brought in the big gut with
the big guy Global Marketing VP I guess
would be far superior to Alyssa who was
like uh just the US domestic oh boy
YouTube's not going to be happy about
this one you see and this is my point
there is no way they made a move this
bold because you know when you're
working in corporate and you've got
marketing people and PR people they're
gonna say you do this it is dropping a
boulder in a lake it is going to Ripple
out everyone's going to be talking about
it you are reigniting the story but they
knew they had to do it yeah that's how
bad it was what is that says to me it is
extremely likely as I believed as I
mentioned earlier as I believe that they
went to YouTube and said take these
video videos down or else what if it was
a coordinated effort and they were like
listen for our business we have to fire
the people that did this or we're not
going to recover our Revenue but at the
same time we want to serve this leftist
agenda or our ESG score so how about you
remove all the criticism of Dylan
Mulvaney we remove our marketing team
and it like evens out I don't that makes
no sense like there's there's no
strategy here what the the fact that
they are removing this woman she's
taking a leave of absence maybe it was
of her own volition but not apologizing
says a lot which is where you're
probably right that they don't want to
besmirch the the good name of ESG right
but they know they're reeling from it
and it'll right so they're the two moves
maybe if they did if they did pressure
YouTube at the same time to be like hey
we're gonna if you don't remove this
stuff and then also this then they can
be like well we did both we're serving
both yeah man it would have been way
easier oh I'm sorry no I was excited to
be interesting if she quietly comes back
you know she's going to leave absence
different Terminator or like in six
months when they think this has come
down because you're completely right to
him like their sales are hurting and
it's the beginning of the second quarter
of the year like they need to fix this
as quickly as possible so it doesn't
carry in I mean I can only imagine that
summer is a pretty intense sales uh time
for a year right like they don't want to
go into their second quarter which is
probably a serious sales quarter for
them with this boycott still in place
and I really just don't think a leave of
absence is enough right like I don't
want to advocate for anyone to get fired
on the other hand she has really hurt
the company if they quietly sneak her
back in in June it's not going to look
good
hmm it might be a legal thing it'll be
interesting to watch it'll be
interesting to see if people keep
watching to see if she exits the company
or if she's reinstated yeah and I'm sure
they're like she's a female executive we
can't just fire her over this like that
will hurt us as well I'm scrambling to
learn more about it right now but it's
it's just such fresh knowledge uh I
don't know much to say about it yet you
know my compassion is there for this
girl but still you know I mean the
market the market demands you know
you're going to follow the market for
your decisions right so this this news
is coming out on a Friday
obviously PR 101 let the story die but
they tried this last week it did not
work they're trying it again it will not
work I'll tell you what's going to
happen Monday morning first thing there
will be a wave of political commentary
talking about just this the old rules
don't work anymore it used to be that by
Monday there was different news in the
news outlets were like what story should
we run guys and the editor comes into
the room and he's like here's a bunch of
stories that happened over the weekend
here's what we got from last night what
about that story from Friday that's old
news now there's too much online so
there's going to be a ton of people who
are going to be like here's what you
missed last weekend and they're going to
start with the biggest story Bud Light
has for for whatever reason either of
our own volition or otherwise she has
been removed from her position
so uh well next Monday morning we're
going to have news on this and
everyone's going to want to know they
need to just apologize bud just
apologize just say we're sorry for
sponsoring Dylan Mulvaney we're sorry we
won't do it again but but you gotta say
why you're sorry yeah agreed there's I I
think I think if Anheuser-Busch came out
and said we literally did not understand
the political ramifications of what this
person means to people in this country
we did not understand that that it was a
highly hyper polarizing issue we do not
here's what I'd say I'd say
first I'd say I'm to all of our loyal
you know Bud Light fans and drinkers I
am deeply sorry that we sponsored an
individual that was off-putting and
offensive to you we didn't mean to do
that
we did not realize how strongly people
felt about this because we did not know
the context around this story and this
individual so here's what we're gonna do
we are going to rescind the sponsorship
we will strive to avoid this kind of
thing again we just want people to come
together over an ice cold brew and
celebrate with each other and if this
didn't accomplish that we screwed up
please forgive us would you buy Bud
Light if they said that yes
really I think I think there are people
who wouldn't I think they would say like
if you didn't know he was a polarizing
figure then you are still lying then the
damage is done yeah but what they're
playing right now is do nothing say
nothing and hope it goes away and it's
getting worse well this is this is going
to be the debate in in conservative
circles over the course of the next week
is what to do because they fired this
woman and whether the boycotting
of absence okay leave of absence at a
corporation we know what that means
she may have said guys I'm stepping down
I I can't be involved in this right it's
possible they could have gone to her and
said we want you to take a leave of
absence we don't know for sure what if
she comes back like what if they're like
yeah there won't be a news story about
it if she does right they'll do it as
quietly as possible and then I feel like
conservatives are gonna have to be like
oh wait they just completely took back
the person who I assume it okay had the
most authority to let this happen like
what does that say about the company
the only I can speak for myself here and
I would not buy Anheuser-Busch products
unless they not only issued an apology
that actually said we apologize but they
stated that what they did and named what
they did was wrong and also it's not she
just stepped in it not just we didn't
realize it was hot button issue but they
had to say we're sorry for sponsoring
this person we're sorry because it
violates your values we understand that
we ask for your forgiveness moving on
like we're not going to do that again
that I I'm happy to forgive them if they
say that but if they just say these if
they just keep doing the things that
they're doing I'm I'm done yeah I want
to see them specify that his audience is
very young too young and they didn't
realize how young his audience was and
that there that was a gross misconduct
on their part also it's inbev a b in Bev
is the company that owns Anheuser-Busch
a b and Bev owes the humanity and
apology for for trying to sell their
beer to kids
someone said they saw a video saying Bud
Light is being sued but they are being
sued they're being sued by America First
legal for racist hiring practices
so they just opened a can of worms on
this one I think the issue is especially
with that lawsuit
Bud Light is the easiest culture War
issue for the average person there's no
brand loyalty to watered-down beer
the beer for people who don't want to
drink beer but want to drink a lot of it
there's a bunch of options for alcoholic
water there's hard Seltzer there's uh
you know other light beers I'm not gonna
I'll try not out to avoid insulting the
other beers that are doing fine because
they didn't engage in this practice but
really
I think the issue is Dylan Mulvaney is
Nails on a chalkboard to many people
that's why there's no boycott right now
over Jack Daniels or cores other
companies have done Pride promotions
Dylan Mulvaney specifically is is a very
grading individual who deeply offends a
lot of people for a variety of reasons
and I think I think uh the transgender
issue is just one small aspect I think
it's the political aspect people hyper
focus on but I think for a lot of people
it's just the I really do think it's the
narcissistic personality disorder and I
would give the prices Right video as an
example of it yeah people were deeply
bothered by Dylan Mulvaney on The Price
is Right and Dylan in that video is just
some guy like not trans not expressing
any ideology but people are saying look
at this Behavior it's off-putting it's
it's shocking it's offensive it's wrong
it's narcissistic that carries through
and I actually think that Dylan Mulvaney
uses trans people as a shield for this
while simultaneously making them look
bad like there are there are people that
we shout out periodically who are trans
themselves who are great people that we
we love and respect Dylan Mulvaney is so
long as Don Mulvaney is the most
prominent individual claiming to be
trans it is going to be very very
difficult for run-of-the-mill regular
trans people to be taken seriously
that's something that I find deeply
offensive that Dylan will like Dil
Mulvaney I'll say it again hiking heels
in the forest yeah and and there are
people conservatives who've never met a
trans person who see that and they're
like that's what this is it's like no no
no hang out with Blair white Blair's
amazing super cool that does not
represent who these people are but now
YouTube is shutting down people who are
critical of that and it's almost like
YouTube hates trans people too or
they're I think it comes down to
YouTube really doesn't care they're just
like whatever makes us money I literally
don't care if Dylan Mulvaney is the
worst example of of of a person in media
who is insulting women and trans people
at the same time if it makes us money
just take the action well it's also the
phrase you said I think is key for a lot
of women and that is in a very insulting
portrayal of a quote-unquote woman right
like think about the very first days of
girlhood video where sitting behind the
keyboard being like okay my first day of
being a woman I wrote an angry email
that I didn't send I cried a couple of
times I all these the very misogynistic
stereotypes of of a woman I saw that and
I was like excuse me I've been a woman
for 33 years I haven't done any of that
but you know what people who hate women
accuse women accuse women of behaving
like that what's and and what if Dylan
Mulvaney said my first day of Womanhood
I went to the kitchen made a sandwich
and did the dishes and folded the
laundry like what's the difference it's
the same stereotype insult I mean I
think part of it is like
is this the type of humor you think oh
I'm relating to you by also nagging on
myself but the reality is you are not
experiencing these things it's a similar
stereotyping that bothers me when people
say oh well we have this song but he
thinks he's transgender and so we
socially transitioned him and it's like
your 12 year old is wearing so much eye
shadow I can't see his face and tons of
eyeliner like I wouldn't let my 12 year
old daughter do that like you are taking
parts of being female and
inappropriately applying them to a
situation in a lot of ways but also like
the weird or like the parts of like
mature female adulthood like it just
doesn't make sense and it's okay in some
cases and not in other people no woman
that I've ever met no woman that I've
ever met behaves the way that Dylan
Mulvaney does right and no woman would
be accepted in a professional setting or
taken seriously if she behaved that way
but additionally
most trans people don't behave that way
I think one of the issues that we're
dealing with in popular culture is the
highlighting of key individuals who are
clearly bad examples there was a video
that went viral the other day of a trans
person threatening extreme violence and
that's like one crazy person you then
had the the Nashville incident you have
the extreme examples of narcissism from
people like Dylan Mulvaney and then you
have many other people that I mentioned
we know and care about who don't behave
like that at all so the the issue for me
is if someone is experiencing a mental
illness or mental disorder of any type
we want that person to get help some
people have a multitude of disorders and
illnesses in different in different
areas I'm not going to lump them all
together I'm going to say here's an
individual who is experiencing this
disorder or or mental illness and
they'll be treated in this way and then
you get a combination of a few who are
either threatening extreme violence I'm
not going to blame the person on the
left for the actions of the person on
the right you see you know you're not
trying to say this distinction that
you're making is perhaps between people
who suffer from gender dysphoria versus
people who have been captured by the
ideology this is we were talking about
this right before we went on air this is
what I'm speaking about at James Madison
University on Wednesday it's why the
radical trans activists are agitating
before I get there because I'm talking
about the ideology of transgenderism
which doesn't have anything to do with
the surgeries anything to do with the
Pharmaceuticals doesn't have anything to
do with the biology nothing nothing like
that per se it's that that queer Theory
which a lot of people haven't heard
about queer theory is actually the
ideological underpinning of this
movement to capture vulnerable Youth and
the vulnerability might be any number of
things whether it's abuse whether it's
other these comorbidities whatever it
might be the vulnerability is there this
ideology comes in and says hey you don't
feel right about something you feel
unhappy the solution is to disassociate
yourself from your previous identity and
to take on this new identity and set it
all solve all your problems and I think
that the distinction that you make
between people that feel a discomfort in
their body versus people captured by the
ideology is probably true exactly Dylan
Mulvaney pushes the ideology without I I
think it's it's very very obvious if
we're talking about someone who's
suffering from gender dysphoria an
individual who looks in the mirror and
experiences anxiety and this like mental
anguish over a misalignment with their
perception and their body that's gender
dysphoria Dylan Mulvaney goes on camera
and yells about their body and says look
at my bulge and things like that which
when I've asked people who are actually
experiencing genitis for you they're
like a person with dysphoria would not
yell to 10 million people look at my
male body parts because that would
trigger their dysphoria and so then
there's questions about autogynophilia
and Otto androphilia but Don Mulvaney
seems to be just an individual who
desperately wants to be famous as as uh
the example being Ellen Degeneres and
The Price is Right video so that's
that's even outside of the ideology
that's Fame desperation yeah but but I
agree with you you're right there there
was a period where many trans people
were actually being canceled by gender
activists I guess I guess we refer to as
gender ideology or critical gender
Theory or something like that there was
this period where there were a lot of
trans people saying there are only two
Sexes hence if you're trans you
transition to the other yeah but the
younger generation with Z zims or and
Neo pronouns believe there's a plethora
of genders in which case
transition can be from any gender that's
the that's the ideological part of it
right which is at odds with someone
who's dysphoric right it's like it's
like the way that I compare it is you
know take it back three or four years
ago and we saw in our schools when it
came to like the black lives matter
riots and the racial tension that was in
our country we saw our children being
taught this poisonous stuff like if
you're a white child that you're
inherently racist based on the color of
your skin if you're a black child you're
oppressed based on the color of your
skin and we all kind of pointed to that
and said wait a second that's not right
like that's that's bad we don't want our
kids being taught that and it took a
little bit of time to unpack the fact
that this wasn't some random poisonous
ideology that this was critical race
Theory it was the principles of critical
race theory that were being taught not
being taught as CRT but being being
taught with this ideological
underpinning and when we started
realizing when those of us on the Right
started realizing that the left said no
critical race theory is just teaching
accurate history it's just making sure
that children represented slavery and we
were like no no no no no critical race
theory is the grand child of critical
theory which is a neo-marxist ideology
that exact same thing that exact same
trajectory is happening with with queer
Theory and with the with this um
epidemic of people identifying as
transgender we see this happening in
schools we're like we don't want our
kindergartners being taught about sex
about gender identity we don't we don't
want these groomer teachers we identify
that we don't like that and we're just
now as a society being like wait a
second this is not just some random
garbage that's being taught this is the
these are the outgrowth of queer Theory
it's the principles of the underlying
ideology and that's where we are right
now thanks for watching this clip from
the timcast IRL podcast hang out with us
live Monday through Friday at 8 pm and
become a member over at timcast.com for
uncensored members only shows exclusive
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time